hi everybody mark albert along with
chris collinsworth and
chris i don't care what anybody else on
the staff has said i i think you look
just
excellent in that jacket thank you you
did a great job designing them marv i
i think you were terrific with that it's
about time that i received
some credit
wow i i wonder if any of those jackets
somebody's
insistence if somebody didn't like that
jacket i'm guessing it's collinsworth
he's probably going what i gotta put
this on
are you kidding me i i wonder i wonder
what would happen if you try to burn one
of those things it'd be like a rubber
fire
man that is that's a lot of leather or
pleather or whatever it is there
whatever that is that's an old high
grade naugahyde i like the purple
i do too that's like what year you think
that is i mean that's
old giant stadium and that's that jets
game there so that's right
that's got 1992 just written all over it
oh yeah
you know it's i was gonna say maybe a
little later and go like 95 or something
like that but yeah you're right it's
somewhere in that
that range that's that weird cusp
between the 80s and the 90s where
everyone was kind of trapped between the
two decades i'd say 92.
okay see if we can find that out all
right marv albert is retiring after the
nba
season one of the all-time greats so uh
we've decided to draft today the best
nfl announcer catch phrase
chris because you got the impromptu
trivia question right earlier the only
heisman winner to come from a team with
a losing record
paul horning notre dame you get the
first pick
in this draft very nice of you thank you
very much um
i i you know when i was growing up
summerall and madden was i mean that was
life and especially for a giants
football team in the 80s i mean i just
felt like every sunday i was listening
to
to john madden pat sumrall and john
madden especially
i mean his famous catch phrase is not
even like
english that's the best part about it
and this guy went here it's just a boom
boom boom i mean it was amazing it was
the coolest thing ever
i mean a guy that made no sense at all
it made sense
and was awesome it was awesome on tv his
handwriting and circles were absolutely
pitiful and horrible
but it looked awesome and just was the
delivery was great
so uh for me that's as good as it gets
growing up as a little kid and even back
now when i hear him i'm always like
i perk up legend for sure i think the
word you're searching for is
boom yes i think that would be the
catchphrase for madden right and what he
combined he combined
the credibility of being a football guy
a coach a guy who had been there and
done that knew how the sausage was made
but he had that infectious energy and
his approach to the game
was inclusive that's one of the things
that
some announcers will trip into in order
to impress others with their knowledge
of the game they
alienate the average fan by making it
seem more complicated than it is right
madden went the other way he did he made
it seem
far more simple than it really is which
made you wonder
is it really a lot more simple than the
people inside the bubble want us to
think it is
yeah i hear you you're right and i think
there's some that would probably go
i mean to your point or that point go no
it's not it's still about hitting
tackling
who's the most physical all those type
of things you're right but he
he kept it very elementary
and i know that's i i know like you know
my aunt wendy we talk about all the time
yeah that she'd be the person that loved
john madden and that type of stuff yeah
he wasn't getting into like
oh and cover two they're reading this
slot receiver and all that
yeah ninety 90 of the fans don't want to
hear that crap don't even know what it
means it just doesn't matter
uh and he he kept it good for for all
people watching which was amazing
and you know when i was a kid it was pat
sumrall and tom brookshire if they had
the game
it was necessarily a big game that's how
you knew
that's how you knew because they're at
the game that is the big game of the
week and then it became eventually
summer all in madden and
you know this was more of a college
football dynamic and i'm sorry that i'm
gonna
deviate from the rules here but he now
does nfl
games for the las vegas raiders on radio
but there was nothing that got the goose
bumps going the the you know
just that that that tingling sensation
that this game is the right deal
then hearing brent musberger say you are
looking live that
that was the message that the next three
hours of your life
will not be wasted even if
it ends up being a blowout at the front
end
you had a feeling that this was a big
time game a special game an
important game settle in get your
popcorn get your beverage of choice
and get ready to enjoy some football
yeah you're right i mean listen i i
don't think you're cheating here
yeah like i know he announced like all
the college games but even like
again growing up he would kick it to the
games right from nfl studios and cbs yes
and you just that voice there
you know we're going live you know
however you said it right i mean yes you
are looking live
you're looking live you yeah you know
you are looking like i got the boom in
before too with it
it got yeah you're funny uh and you're
sure
all right i really don't like you all
right here we go too late you already
said it all right
um i'm gonna go with dick enberg as my
next one
i mean again i know i'm going back to my
childhood but legend like oh my
oh oh my i mean that was i i wish i
could do his voice better
but like him i could just remember
watching
nbc it's like broncos and elway afc
championship sunday and elway makes a
great throne it's
oh my what a throw by john elway like
that was just amazing so
uh dick enberg just had like that silky
smooth voice and unbelievable delivery
the ultimate professional and to me oh
my is one of the great catch phrases in
sports history um you know it's funny i
had an inspiration there because the
catchphrase has to be something that you
use on a regular basis yeah
i i i heard joe buck saying that is a
disgusting act when randy moss pretended
to moon the crowd at lambeau field but
that was a one-time thing
it has to be something that you use on a
regular basis
ideally every week it reminds me of the
great sitcoms when you just
waited when you waited for that one
character without one line to say did i
do that or whatever it was
so that's the true catch phrase and
that's why my next one
goes way back to my own youth back in
the glory days of monday night football
when it was frank gifford howard cosell
and danny dawn marriage yeah he knew
when the game was over his catchphrase
was his song turn out the lights the
party's over
them and and you know it's funny in in
because my guess is like initially the
producers were pissed off that he would
do it not not like there were other
choices for people to change the channel
to in those days but nowadays
anything you would say to suggest that
there's reason to turn the station to
something else
you'd get chastised for he was basically
saying
go ahead and turn off the tv go watch
something else go do anything else this
thing's over
yeah that that would have been my my i
was really hoping you kind of maybe
forgot about it
i probably should have picked it earlier
because you're ain't that old
i mean i'm old enough to remember it i'm
not old enough to forget it well i don't
know you for a second there you were
filibustering and everything there i was
going man mike's not prepared today he's
coming up with something
fully prepared all right i just wanted i
sent all my picks last night
did you really damn i don't ever send my
picks the night before there's no chance
that's happening
but uh you don't want to sing it for us
like you're not you're not even gonna
you're not even gonna give us to turn
out the lights the party's over ain't
nothing okay fine
we'll do a duet you wanna do it no i
don't wanna i wanna solo by you that's
what i want all right fine
johnny kiss man all right um all right
now i'm stuck
i i i feel like speaking of not prepared
well no i have some i have
i have two ready to go i want to pick
pat sumrall cause he's on the board but
you're right he has no catchphrase
but i am going to talk about him for a
second anyways i don't give a damn all
right
uh pat sumrall i do well yeah
exactly can i use that like matt casey
just said touchdown like
to me his catch phrase was the fact of
he could call a play
with the least amount of words in the
history of announcing
it would be like montana rice
touchdown i mean that's a i grew up with
it sims
bovaro touchdown so
i know what i wish i could do all right
i'm going to use that yeah pat summerall
touchdown i don't know
this screw off it's it's my draft i'm
taking who i want i'm going to do that
i did i know you could do whatever you
want i know i did think about
you know um bill king with the raiders
and holy tolino
right that one you know that that's a
really good one and then i do think of
my gene deckerhoff over down in tampa
bay with
far the curtains like that was two that
i was going to go with
if i didn't go with pat sumrall but i
got to go with sumrall
the one thing about summerhall and pete
demelitis is sending us the video link
and i encourage everyone to check it out
he turned his reads for the cbs
primetime programming specifically the
program murders
he wrote in the theater right with his
paws
murder between murder [ __ ] she wrote
because there's a comma after murder in
the title to the show
so they did have fun in their own way
yeah and summer always just
you know former kicker who became one of
the best
if not the best play-by-play voices of
all time it's
look it's there's a price to be paid for
chain smoking
but it does give you one hell of a voice
one hell of a voice
john fasenda pat summer i'll smoke those
cigarettes because
man it resonates it's baritone and it's
memorable
and uh uh uh yeah i mean pat pat sumrall
was
the guy that's the common link whether
it was tom brookshire
john madden whoever when it was pat
summerall
that was a big deal yeah he lived to 83
too damn i mean that's so that's good
you won
you get to the 80s you win so i mean
smoke cigarettes sounded awesome
and got to the 80s win win win for pat
sumrall but
yeah amazing i mean really and his voice
was like that
in person too i i could just as a young
kid
can still remember the few saturday
practices i was at and pat sumrall and
john madden walking around the field
talking as the giants were going through
a walk through on those days and i used
to watch them more than i watched the
giants
and even pat sumrall would say hi you'd
hear that voice man just
just amazing last one for me and this is
not a national voice but this is one of
my
few good friends in the business paul
allen
the catchphrase that i think i it came
from his horse racing i know this i've
talked to him about it
because he does horse racing in
minnesota
and he used it for adrian peterson when
adrian peterson started to bust those
75-yard
touchdown runs and he's loose and he
yells it and it is awesome and uh
i he he does it when he's confident he's
not going to get caught
and that's it and the guy's gone and i
he still does it i think he was going to
try to retire it
when adrian peterson left the vikings
but he still uses it
for the vikings games when the guy when
it's dalvin cook or whoever
whoever gets free and he's loose it can
be a defensive return it could be a kick
return whatever it
is and he's loose once he's loose wow
you are
just some you kiss ass of a friend i'll
tell you look at you they're calling you
look at you i unbelieve wearing a purple
shirt
just showing total vikings favoritism
over here that's what you're doing
unbelievable you're the one that was
talking about firing the cannons
when you were in tampa they were firing
the cannons at you well yeah
they were firing the cannon because i
was doing pick six or don't yeah i don't
know yeah you're right there get this
guy off the field
that's why you threw the football into
the cannon hole that was your defense
against the cannonball
that's right shut that damn thing up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports